for you what's been coming up for you
emotionally nothing much emotionally
okay I don't really like dating so what
do you not like about dating I think
dating is boring it's hard for me to
know if this person's going to be worth
my time and I'd rather spend time with
my friends than like meet someone new or
meet someone organically somewhere yeah
yeah so every relationship I've ever
been on been in I've been friends with
them first okay yeah yeah the friends to
lovers Trope we love a friends to lovers
Trope yeah of my favorites when it's
friends to lovers thing like I already
know they're worth my time yeah when did
you start dating Rel my first
relationship was in 9th grade okay he
had a crush on two girls one of them was
me one was this other girl and he was
trying to decide who to take to
homecoming who did he take me obviously
and and then we were like in a
relationship and then he was like I love
you and I was like what and then we
broke up 2 months later